Hallo und herzlich willkommen zum Chaos Radio 267, wo wir heute an einem Wochenende Deutschland völlig umsonst zu einem besseren Platz machen, die Welt retten und das beste Computerspiel aller Zeiten programmieren. Was heißt das? Das heißt, wir reden heute über Hackathons oder Jams oder wie auch immer man das bezeichnet, wenn sich ein paar Leute für kurze Zeit auf einen Haufen setzen und versuchen möglichst kreativ zu sein. Und das hört sich ja alles total gut an. So eine Kreativparty quasi. Aber es wäre natürlich kein technisches Thema, wenn man das nicht auch völlig kaputt machen könnte oder missbrauchen sogar. Und wir reden heute über alles, was man damit anstellen kann, was das ist, wo es herkommt, wofür es benutzt wird und was man damit machen können sollte vielleicht. Anlass, also das Thema ist schon ein bisschen länger da. Anlass ist, dass es jetzt tatsächlich etwas gibt, das Update Deutschland heißt, wo versucht, wo eben genau das versucht werden soll, dass eben Leute zusammenkommen und dann in einem kurzen Zeitraum sich eine technische Lösung für ein Problem ausdenken können. Und ich bin, ich hab das, weil mein Kopf gerade mit anderen Themen voll ist, gar nicht so sehr verfolgt, sondern immer noch aus dem Augenwinkel gesehen, dass es da auch dann Kritik gibt, so Schlagworte wie, man kann für gesellschaftliche Probleme keine technischen Lösungen finden. Und mir scheint das Thema als besprechenswürdig. Und deswegen freue ich mich sehr, die heutigen Gäste begrüßen zu dürfen. Das sind Lilith, Julia und Stefan. Hallo und guten Abend. So, damit das geneigte Publikum, die HörerInnen euch kennenlernen können, wüsste ich jetzt gerne von jedem einzelnen von euch, wo ihr eigentlich herkommt, was ihr heute hier erzählen wollt und wie ihr mit dem Thema in Berührung steht. Also wo ihr herkommt, auch im Bezug auf das inhaltliche Thema. Keine ganz old written story. Julia, vielleicht fängst du an.
Ja, gerne. Ich wohne gerade in Osnabrück und ich wurde eigentlich von hier aus sozusagen einmal in ganz Deutschland über Hackathons sozialisiert, weil ich eigentlich bisher immer nur heimliche Techie war und schon länger Linux benutzt, mir auch so Programmieren beigebracht habe und dann aber Germanistik und Soziologie studiert habe und über Jugendhackt dann so ein bisschen in die Technikwelt reingekommen bin. Und das war für mich, wie ich Hackathons kennengelernt habe. Und irgendwann habe ich gemerkt, ach nee, da gibt es auch noch ganz andere Formen von, die nicht ganz so kuschlig und flauschig sind.
Ich muss gerade ein bisschen lachen. Für hüte schützt eure Kinder vor Linux, weil dann studieren sie Soziologie. Stefan, Entschuldigung. Ich bin sich aus der Bahn geworfen, haben wir einfach schon. Stefan, wo kommst du her? Die Geschichte geht ja auch andersrum. Also ich habe zuerst Medieninformatik studiert und bin dann erst zu Linux gekommen. Also der späte Einstieg hat mich vor Soziologie, nein stimmt gar nicht, es hat mich zumindest vor Gamanistik bewahrt. Liebe Geisteswissenschaftler, das sind nur schale abgestandene Scherzen von Menschen, die es wissen. Wir meinen euch nichts Böses. Ganz im Gegenteil, es ist ja eigentlich genau richtig, mit der soziologischen Brille auch draufzuschauen. Aber das mal beiseite, also ich reingefunden habe ich zuerst tatsächlich bei so Hackathons im Sinne von wir eignen uns eine Technik an übers Wochenende. Ich bin da mit einigen anderen reingerutscht während meiner viel zu langen Studienzeit, dass wir eigentlich so ja Dinge mit Open Data machen wollten und bin da reingekommen in das Thema. Wir haben dann auch durch eine Kollegin, Studienfreundin, auch Jugendhackt tatsächlich umgesetzt da vor Ort bei uns. Und irgendwann bin ich dann durch Zufälle zum hauptamtlichen Schreibtisch Hooligan bei einer kleinen Stadtverwaltung geworden, der eigentlich das reintragen soll, was diese Zivilgesellschaft so macht, wie man wie man eine Kommune besser machen könnte in die Kommune selber. Okay, da sind schon jede Menge Fremdwörter schon in den Vorstellungen. Open Data, Jugendhackt. Hatten wir das hier auch schon mal in der Sendung? Müssen wir aber trotzdem noch mal erklären nachher. Aber bevor wir das machen, Lilith.
Ja, ich bin über den CCC zu Linux gekommen. Da war ich so 15 und hab so angefangen, auf den Kongress zu gehen. Und genau, hab dann irgendwann angefangen, als Softwareentwicklerin zu arbeiten. Und bin dann einfach auch immer wieder mit dem Thema Hackathon in Berührung gekommen. Das erste Mal bei Random Hacks of Kindness, das wurde damals von Google organisiert. Da ging es darum, dass man ein ganz konkretes Problem an einem Wochenende löst. Und ich fand das ganz cool und bin dann über die Jahre hinweg immer mal wieder zu verschiedenen Hackathons gegangen. Und hab das aber vor allem gemacht, um Sachen zu lernen. Und bin in den letzten zwei Jahren eigentlich so immer mehr mit so Verwaltungsdigitalisierung und so Themen in meiner Freizeit in Berührung gekommen. Und hab dadurch natürlich auch Wir versus Virus und Update Deutschland so ein bisschen verfolgt und mich damit beschäftigt, wie weit das eigentlich von dem entfernt ist, was wir vielleicht gesellschaftlich wirklich brauchen. Und mein Soziologie-Studium, das gibt es, aber es ist nur ein Hobby. Sehr schön.
Also alle sozusagen aus verschiedenen, aber doch ähnlichen Richtungen damit in Berührung gekommen. Bevor wir jetzt darüber ausführlich reden, was also für Außenstehende, die das Wort gehört haben, ja, da wird jetzt so ein Hackathon gemacht, kann es mal jemand ganz kurz und knapp erklären? Weil die, ich würde sagen, das ist halt wirklich also ein Wochenende vom Klischee her, wo sich Leute treffen und versuchen, sich was zum Programmieren auszudenken. Ich dachte, es geht vielleicht elaborierter oder präziser oder, okay, aber das ist sozusagen, das ist, also wenn man es wirklich ganz breit sieht, ist das ein Hackathon?
Das ist eine Möglichkeit, dass man sich eben genau das Wochenende nimmt und sagt, hey, ich hab entweder Lust, mich mit einer bestimmten Technologie auseinanderzusetzen, eine bestimmte Programmiersprache oder irgendwas, oder ich möchte mich vielleicht mit einem bestimmten Datensatz auseinandersetzen, weil ich das schon immer mal mir näher angucken wollte. Kennen wir ja alle, dass man so schöne Ideen hat. Und dann hat man endlich mal die Möglichkeit und sagt, so, freitags fang ich an, sonntags hör ich auf und versuche so viel wie möglich von dieser Zeit mit genau dieser einen Sache zu verbringen. Das kann aber auch sein, dass es heißt, hey, wir treffen uns einmal, machen quasi eine Art Auftakt und beschäftigen uns dann über Wochen hinweg mit einer bestimmten Sache. Und lernen dabei Dinge oder irgendwas entsteht.
Das hört sich jetzt so an, wie die Leute, die sich da treffen, arbeiten alle an demselben Ding.
Kann sein, muss aber nicht. Auch da finde ich es immer schwierig zu sagen, dass es der Hackathon, weil auch da es natürlich super viele unterschiedliche Sachen gibt. Zum Beispiel, was mir jetzt einfallen würde, wären mal so zwei Beispiele. Wenn es zum Beispiel so ein Wikidata-Hackathon gibt, dann ist das gleiche Ding schon Wikidata. Und irgendwie in dem Rahmen bewegt sich das. Aber tatsächlich kann da natürlich jeder an seinem Interessensgebiet arbeiten. Ob das jetzt ist, weiß ich nicht. Ich möchte gerne mich mit Kulturdaten beschäftigen oder mich eher mit politischen.
Das klingt schon wieder sehr spezifisch, weil das Klischeebild, das ich von Hackathons habe, ist folgendes. Eine größere Rotte von Leuten trifft sich an einem Ort. Dann gibt es möglicherweise einen Überthema oder ein Motto, was das hat. Und dann treffen sie sich auf diesem Event. Also unterteilen die sich in so kleine Gruppen. Und die machen dann zusammen ein Projekt. Und am Ende steht dann ein Prototyp, der den anderen vorgestellt wird. Ich weiß, dass es diese Form von Hackathons gibt. Und ich dachte immer, das ist sozusagen die klassische Form oder die Standardform, wenn man das so nennen kann. Oder ist das der Ausnahmefall?
Na ja, wenn man schaut, wo Hackathons herkommen, dann soweit ich das verstanden hab, ist das nicht, wie es ursprünglich mal war. Also soweit ich das nachvollziehen kann, hat das irgendwann in den early 2000s begonnen, dass man das so genannt hat. Aber eigentlich haben sich Leute in einem Wochenende getroffen und an irgendwelchen Sachen, an denen sie schon vorher gearbeitet haben, zusammen gearbeitet, zusammenarbeiten. Und ich meine, diese Form gibt es ja noch immer. Und ich glaube, dass, wenn man das nur von der Menge an Hackathons, die es so gibt, in dieser ganzen Open Source Welt nimmt, dann gibt es vermutlich deutlich mehr sogar von dieser Art, also dieser Art von Hackathons, wo Leute einfach sich zusammensetzen und an einem bestehenden Problem arbeiten und daran weiterhacken. Ich glaube, dass man gesagt hat, man setzt sich am Freitag hin und hat ein Problem, und am Sonntag sagt man dann, hey, wir haben jetzt irgendeine Lösung für dieses Problem. Das ist zumindest nicht in der klassischen Form, was es mal war, aber das ist das, was, glaube ich, auch in den Medien und Co. weil es halt so ein toll vermarktbares Format ist, das, was dominant ist.
Also das heißt, die ursprüngliche Wortbedeutung von Hackathon ist sozusagen tatsächlich eher Marathon. Also im Sinne von etwas, das man eh schon macht, macht man da mal in einer sehr langen Strecke am Stück. Ja, das kann man so sehen. Ich glaube, wichtig ist, es gibt ja keinen internationalen Standardisierungskörper, der sagt hier Hackathon nach wie so 9, 65. Theoretisch könnten wir uns jetzt zu viert zusammentun und wochenendelang mal tun, was wir schon eh machen wollten. Also man müsste mal Wochenende, da kommt dann nicht die Hackathon-Polizei und sagt, das ist jetzt nicht true und du bist jetzt für immer verstoßen und kriegst eine gelbe Karte oder sowas. Okay, das finde ich schon spannend, weil dann ist das ein Vorurteil von mir gewesen, was ich jetzt mal hinterfragen muss. Wenn mir jemand sagt, wir machen hier einen Hackathon, muss ich immer fragen, was genau denn? Okay, ihr trefft euch anscheinend, aber was genau passiert denn da? Dann habe ich das, glaube ich, aus dem Computerspielebereich eher, weil die Gamejams, die sind, glaube ich, eher tatsächlich in dieser Form, wie ich es gerade... Ich dachte immer, Gamejams sind einfach Hackathons in der Computerspielebranche und die funktionieren meines Wissens eher nach diesem Prinzip, man trifft sich und macht was Neues. Also jammt halt zusammen, aber dann stimmt es wahrscheinlich gar nicht. Also wir haben es uns in der Vorbereitung gefragt und ich fürchte jetzt fast so ein bisschen gesagt, ja, also im Prinzip alle, wenn ich diese Frage stelle, ich will es trotzdem machen. In der Regel, welche Personen oder Organisationen machen denn sowas? Also wo kommt das her und wie ist das jetzt? Also ich glaube, wir können jetzt nicht für alle Hackathons sprechen. Um Gottes Willen in der Regel. Ja genau, also was ich halt sagen kann, mein erster Hackathon, das war vor zehn Jahren, da ging es zum Beispiel darum, das hatte die Node.js Community damals organisiert. Das übergreifende Thema war halt, dass man mit Node.js arbeitet. Und da ist es halt so, da war als Beispiel die Vorgabe, du machst was mit Node.js. Das könnte auch sein, dass die Vorgabe ist, dieses und jenes Thema ist unser Fokus. Oder bei Game Jam, dass man sich auf Spiele fokussiert. Und dann ist es in der Regel so, dass sich halt zunächst Teams finden. Entweder sind die schon vorher gefunden und treten auch als Teams an. Oder die finden sich am ersten Abend zusammen. Also bei Jogen Takt ist das klassischerweise so, dass sich da am ersten Abend Ideen ausgearbeitet werden, was man machen könnte. Und dann finden sich Teams zusammen, die auch dann Interesse haben, das zu tun. Und dann gibt es eben eine Umsetzungsphase, eine Programmierphase oder Umsetzungsphase, die dann das Wochenende lang geht. Und ich glaube, das ist der wichtige Punkt an der Stelle, wenn man dieses gemeinsame Wochenendformat hat. Es gibt halt dann eine Deadline, wo ganz klar ist, bis dahin müsst ihr fertig sein. Also wirklich, dass dieser abgegrenzte Zeitraum da ist. Genau dieses Ding, bis dahin ist es fertig. Und dann kann man es den anderen vorzeigen. Und entweder freut man sich dann einfach nur, was man so gemacht hat und ist gespannt, was die anderen gemacht haben. Oder aber es gibt ja auch dann so Wettbewerbsformate, wo Dinge prämiert werden oder wo die lustigsten oder absurdesten Dinge dann auch noch irgendwie eine besondere Würdigung erfahren. Darüber können wir, glaube ich, nachher nochmal genau sprechen, wie sinnvoll oder was genau der Zweck ist, sozusagen dann hinterher eine Prämierung zu machen. Aber ich würde jetzt erstmal das eine Runde größer fragen wollen, warum eigentlich dieses Format? Also weil ich frage mich das auch gerade, weil es gibt ja unfassbar viele Technikkonferenzen. Und wenn man dann Leute fragt, warum geht denn ihr dahin? Sagen die wenigstens ja wegen der Vorträge, dann sagen die meisten so, na ja, um halt Leute zu treffen fürs Netzwerken. Und deswegen ist auch meine Frage, diese Hackathon als Form des gemeinsamen Machens, ist das auch wieder nur so ein Vorwand, um Leute auf einen Haufen zu bringen und mal zu netzwerken? Oder ist das tatsächlich, wie soll man das sagen, ein Kreativwerkzeug?
Ich glaube, dass man das so pauschal nicht sagen kann. Mein Eindruck ist, dass Hackathons schon dazu tendieren, dass Leute an konkreten Sachen arbeiten. Ich glaube, das Gegenstück, wo man mehr auf Netzwerken fokussiert ist, ist dann eher ein Barcamp. Aber ja, es gibt bestimmt auch Hackathons, wo das nicht so ist. Aber grundsätzlich, von der Idee her, geht es ja schon darum, immer irgendwas konkret zu machen und an einem konkreten Produkt oder an einem konkreten Issue oder was auch immer zu arbeiten.
Ich glaube, genau da kommt auch beides zusammen. Nämlich auf der einen Seite, ich mache ja was, und auf der anderen Seite treffe ich ja Menschen, die sich mit dem Gleichen beschäftigen und komme dadurch mit anderen Menschen zusammen.
Ist das mit dem Menschen, die sich mit dem Gleichen beschäftigen, gibt es so eine Grundvoraussetzung? Also da treffen sich die Profis, um mal jetzt sozusagen mit anderen Profis zu arbeiten? Oder kann das auch ein Modell sein, wo man sagt, wir machen das auch für die Leute, die schon immer mal in dem Bereich was machen wollten, aber selber keine Ahnung, ob sie vielleicht was lernen können oder so was?
Da treffen sich die Profis mit den Profis und dann komm ich und sag, hallo, guten Tag, erklärt mir das doch mal. Also tatsächlich, für mich war das halt wirklich eine großartige Einstiegsmöglichkeit, weil ich dann halt gesehen hab, wie andere damit umgehen. Einfach von einer Fragestellung zu einer Lösung irgendwann zu kommen. Einfach dieses Problem, mit dem sie sich beschäftigt haben. Und damit mein ich jetzt gar nicht so ein riesiges Weltproblem, sondern ein ganz kleines, hier guten Tag, ich möchte eine Webseite bauen, wie mache ich das denn? Wie komme ich da zu einer Lösung? Und habe da einfach zugeguckt, wie das andere machen.
Und das ist auch Teil des Konzepts. Oder das, ich muss jetzt nicht mehr, das kann auch Teil eines solchen Hackathon Konzepts sein. Dass man sagt, das ist durchaus mitgedacht, hier kann man die Dinge lernen, die man macht. Ja, ich glaube, das ist genau der Punkt. Also das Feld ist so riesengroß. Es hängt immer davon ab, was ist die Intention derer, die es veranstalten? Was ist die Intention derer, die daran teilnehmen? Und die müssen sich auch nicht immer decken. Das kann durchaus sein, dass dann Leute auch Veranstaltungen hijacken, weil es da halt ein kostenloses Buffet gibt oder so was in der Richtung. Aber das ist halt, wie wenn du sagst, ich mach ein Sportfest am Wochenende. Also das ist wirklich, das Feld ist sehr groß. Und die Frage ist, was machst du draus? Wenn wir aber heute dann nochmal ausführlicher über das aktuelle Beispiel der Update Deutschland reden wollen, dass es schon im Sinne von, also über die Sinnhaftigkeit können wir nochmal sprechen, aber es ist schon eigentlich gedacht, als da trifft man sich, um dann ein neues Projekt, Produkt, Ding zu entwickeln, oder?
Genau, die Idee ist, dass verschiedene Kommunen zum Beispiel oder ein Bundesland oder der Bund kommt und sagt, wir haben Problem X und jetzt löst das doch mal in einem Wochenende, weil das zuvor noch niemand gelöst hat, aus deren Sicht.
Beziehungsweise der Entwickler eine Idee, wie man das lösen kann. Und dann gibt es ja meistens irgendwelche angeschlossenen Fortsetzungsprogramme, wo man das dann in die Realität umsetzen kann. Das heißt, da legen sie ja auch immer sehr viel Wert drauf. Also immer sage ich jetzt von den zwei großen, die ich im Kopf habe dazu, nämlich Update Deutschland und Wir versus Virus, wo es dann darum geht, ihr braucht ja nur erstmal eine Idee. Und dann könnt ihr sie weiterentwickeln.
Aber das, was die Intention ist, wissen wir halt nicht genau. Wir können nur sehen, was die öffentlich verlautbaren und können das daran ableiten. Also die tieferen Ziele, da muss man interpretieren, was sie halt sagen. Wir können nochmal zu Jugendhack. Also es gibt zu Jugendhack übrigens noch eine ganz eigene Folge, die verlinken wir auch in den Show Notes. Aber kurz um das nochmal zu sagen, da kommen ja Jugendliche, also es gibt das in Deutschland weit und dann auch sozusagen in regionaler, da kommen Jugendliche oder Heranwachsende, kann man vielleicht besser sagen, zusammen, um eben ein Wochenende Projekt zu entwickeln. Und das dient tatsächlich auch der Vernetzung der Menschen, die da aufschlagen. Aber auch da, also da passiert es auch manchmal, dass ich war da lange bei der Abschlusspräsentation immer dabei, passiert es auch manchmal, dass Leute an Dingen arbeiten, die es schon gibt. Aber da entstehen auch ganz viele Ideen vor Ort. Und jetzt habt ihr hier gesagt, bei dem Wir-Wirst-das-Virus in Update Deutschland ist das auch gedacht, um Lösungen zu entwickeln. Ich muss tatsächlich nochmal fragen, diese Hackathons zumindest in dieser ganz konkreten Form, ist das ein Kreativitätswerkzeug? Also bringt das tatsächlich was? Also wir finden uns zusammen und machen das unter Zeitdruck. Und ist es vielleicht ein Blick von außen, weil man sich auch, weil man unbekannte Reiche vordringen kann? Oder ist das nur so ein Versprechen, was das gar nicht einlöst? Oder andersrum gefragt. Und für euch, wart ihr schon mal bei einem Hackathon und seid dadurch, dass es eben dieses spezielle Format ist, auf Dinge gekommen, die eben durch diese besondere Situation entstanden sind? Ja, definitiv. Also ich glaube, man muss dann immer wieder unterscheiden, was ist der Mehrwert fürs Individuum, das teilnimmt? Und gibt es irgendwas anderes, was ich ableiten kann? Also wenn ich mir, wenn du, du hast Jugendtag angesprochen und da kommen ja auch immer wieder mal ähnliche Ideen dabei raus. Das ist aber überhaupt kein Problem. Weil ich meine, die Projekte, die da entstehen, die sind ja kein Selbstzweck, sondern da steht ja im Vordergrund, dass Jugendliche erstens mal auch mitbekommen, von wegen ich kann einen Einfluss nehmen. Also ich bin ja nicht nur irgendwie Konsumentin, sondern ich kann auch selber was schaffen, was machen. Und sie bekommen ja auch diesen Spirit mit, dass das ja in einem Kontext steht, wo sie aktiv Einfluss auf die Welt nehmen sollen, die sich ihnen so stellt, die sie vorfinden. Dass sie nicht nur einfach so durchs Leben wandern, sondern dass sie da wirklich was ändern können. Das ist jetzt die Frage, ob man das jetzt auf die Art und Weise so im Vordergrund stellen sollte, nach dem Motto, mach eine App und damit kannst du schon einen riesen Impact haben. Aber darum geht es glaube ich nicht, sondern da geht es wirklich um den Lernerfolg, um auch andere kennenzulernen, die ähnliche Hobbys haben, die man vielleicht selber in der eigenen Schule nicht hat oder im eigenen Dorf nicht hat. Und da geht es nicht darum, also niemand würde rangehen und sagen, ihr macht jetzt ein Wochenende was und damit rettet ihr die Wale oder die Bundesrepublik oder sonst irgendwen. Also du sagst, das kann zwar passieren, aber es sollte nicht der Erwartungsanspruch sein. Um Gottes Willen nein, also, nee. Aber ich habe das Gefühl, du bist geschickt bei einer Frage ausgewichen, nämlich ob du schon mal auf eine kreative Idee oder auf was Neues gekommen bist, aufgrund der besonderen Situation. Ja genau, die habe ich dann vergessen. Die wollte ich nämlich dann im Nachhinein. Also nein, auf jeden Fall. Also es ist ganz oft so, wenn man selber das zum ersten Mal erfährt und erlebt, das ist ja auch cool. Also das ist ja auch Horizontarbeit, dann da mal auf Fragestellung zu kommen, was kann ich damit bearbeiten, wie kann ich dann Impact haben, was kann ich ändern. Was aber ganz oft passiert ist, wenn man dann mit Institutionen zusammenarbeitet. Also gerade wenn man jetzt aus diesem Bereich des Digitalen Ehrenamts, Civic Tech, Open Data, die ganzen Begriffe, die du vorhin sagtest, die man noch unbedingt erklären müssen, wenn man da herkommt, dann trifft man ja immer wieder auf den Zustand, dass das ja in Strukturen schon verankert ist. Also das ist eine Gemeinde oder das ist mein Bundesland oder der Bund selber, der da eigentlich dahinter steckt. Dem kann man dann zwar antragen von wegen so und so, könnte man das anders, könnte man es besser machen, aber die Umsetzung liegt bei den öffentlichen Stellen. Und da hackt es dann meistens. Ich finde es interessant zu sagen, wie du die Frage noch ganz kurz beantwortest. Wie hast du dich an deinem Schreibtisch hooligierend? Vielleicht sind das der letzte Spuren. Julia, kannst du vielleicht kurz erzählen, ob du schon das als Kreativwerkzeug nutzen konntest oder beobachtet hast?
Ich würde sagen auf jeden Fall, weil wenn ich mich so frage, was ist eigentlich Kreativität, dann heißt es ja immer neue Ideen. Und neue Ideen entstehen für mich eigentlich vor allem dann, wenn ich mit anderen Menschen in Kontakt komme. Und dann würde ich auf jeden Fall sagen, ich kann jetzt gar nichts so Konkretes benennen, aber ich glaube, das kennt jeder, der mal mit anderen irgendwo rum sitzt. Und man fängt an, sich mit Gleichgesinnten irgendwie über Sachen auszutauschen. Und auf einmal fangen an, irgendwelche Ideen, so absurd sie auch sein mögen, aus einem rauszusprudeln. Und ich glaube, diesen Effekt gibt es auf jeden Fall. Die Frage ist dann halt, bringt das irgendwas? Also sind das einfach nur absurde Ideen? Oder kann man damit auch irgendwas anfangen? Und ich glaube, da hängt es einfach ganz stark davon ab, wer die anderen Menschen sind, die mit einem im Raum sind.
Aber ich dachte, da würden Hackathons die Möglichkeit geben, das schon in einem ganz frühen Stadion tatsächlich auszuprobieren. Weil man ein bisschen mehr Zeit hat, kann man die Idee nicht nur haben, sondern auch den Versuch einer Umsetzung übernehmen. Es gibt ja diesen komischen Spruch, was gegen die Wand werfen, gucken, was kleben bleibt. So dachte ich, kann das vielleicht auch sein.
Ich glaube, ehrlich gesagt, die besten Ideen kommen erst im Laufe der Zeit und eher gegen Ende, wann man merkt, was alles nicht funktioniert hat. Das ist halt wirklich so die Sache. Nur aus sich selbst heraus. Ich finde es auch immer lustig, dass ich das sehr stark mit Deutschland verbinde. Ein gewisser Geniekult, das kommt alles aus dir selber raus. Du hast die Erleuchtung, wo ich mir denke, ich habe freitags abends keine Erleuchtung. Aber wenn ich sonntags ein paar Sachen durchprobiert und durchgedacht habe, dann schon eher.
Okay, Lilith? Ich möchte da eigentlich noch mal anschließen. Neue Ideen oder coole Sachen können dabei immer mal entstehen. Aber ich meine, das Problem ist ja dann, dass man das ja in der Regel diese 48 Stunden hat. Und ich hab auch bei Hackathons schon ganz, ganz häufig tolle Ideen gesehen. Und die Leute kommen eigentlich auch immer wieder auf dieselben Ideen. Also da hab ich wirklich so einen Track-Record von seit 2012 bis 2021, welche Ideen ich vielfach auf Hackathons gesehen habe. Aber an Ideen mangelt es halt häufig gar nicht, sondern an der Umsetzung danach. Und ich meine, es ist cool, wenn man 48 Stunden hinsetzt, was ausprobiert, was validiert, einen Versuchsträger baut. In der Regel mangelt es aber dann am Ende in den allermeisten Fällen eher daran, wie führ ich das weiter? Weil ich meine, die Leute können sich 48 Stunden außen im gewissen Rahmen rausziehen von ihrer Arbeit usw. und mal schnell was bauen. Aber das dann langfristig weiter zu betreuen und weiterzuführen, ist ja was ganz anderes. Und der andere Aspekt ist, dass halt auch nach diesen 48 Stunden häufig nicht so Dokumentation oder sowas rauskommt. Was hat man ausprobiert und was nicht? Und wo können andere Leute weitermachen? Und ja.
Also ich höre sozusagen hier so ein ganz großes Ja, aber. Und ich finde das ganz spannend, weil die, ähm... Also ich komme an so ein Thema, hab ja diese Bilder, wir haben schon gerade festgelegt, das eine Bild, das stimmt gar nicht, nämlich dass ein Hackathon eigentlich eine ganz bestimmte Art ist, das zu machen. Und das andere Bild, dachte ich, ist tatsächlich auch eher so ein, dass, äh, dass es toll ist, wenn am Ende dieser 48 Stunden was rausgekommen ist und das es gar nicht so wichtig ist, ist das dann auch weiter realisierbar, kann das weitergetragen werden. Aber ich höre bei euch schon jetzt auch, dass das so ein bisschen, also ein Aber ist, oder so was Unbefriedigendes. Und das finde ich ganz spannend, weil der Begriff Kreativparty hängt bei mir noch so ein bisschen im Kopf rum, aber das scheint nicht genug, oder nicht immer genug zu sein. Ja, also wenn man es jetzt nur auf der Ideenebene hat, dann passt es. Also ultrafiele Ideen an einem Wochenende generieren, perfekt, passt. Das ist überhaupt kein Problem. Ich will jetzt aber auch nicht so sagen, dass da nie was rauskommt. Also ich weiß auch von Projekten, wo einfach an einem Wochenende was fast Komplettes rauskam, oder das heißt, dass es so weit fertig war, dass man das dann noch ein paar Arbeitsstunden hinten ran noch fertig stellen konnte. Also wir hatten da zum Beispiel mal so eine Kampagnenplattform gemacht, wo man im Endeffekt die eigene Postleitzahl eingegeben hat und dann der eigenen Landräte einen Brief schreiben konnte oder einen Fax ausdrucken, dass man mehr Open Data haben wollte. Und das hat gut funktioniert und diese Seite läuft bis heute und passt. Ich muss, ich muss entschuldigen, ich muss an dieser Stelle wirklich lachen, weil technologischer Fortschritt in Deutschland ist, wenn man ein Tool baut, dass es einem erlaubt, was auszudrucken, dass man dann faxen kann. An der Stelle stehen wir heute einfach. Es ist einfach so. Ich will jetzt gar nicht das Tool in Abrede stellen, sondern die Tatsache, dass es notwendig ist. Wir haben zur Sicherheit die Faxnummer mit draufgeschrieben. Ich weiß aber natürlich nicht, wie viele Leute es gefaxt haben. Wir haben bei der Suche auch die Handy-Nummern von manchen Landrätinnen bekommen. Die haben wir natürlich dann auch draufgeschrieben, dass man anrufen kann. So, jetzt ist schon Open Data, Civic Tech und diese beiden Hackathons, die jetzt gerade sozusagen in einer politisierten Umgebung stattfinden. Wir müssen gleich reden. Ich möchte an dieser Stelle noch eine Diskussion jetzt mal einziehen, weil ich glaube, wir kommen nicht dazu, wenn wir dann mit dem ganzen Civic Tech, Open Data etc. zusammenkommen. Und das ist nochmal dieses 48 Stunden nehmen. Das ist ja auch hier wieder ein Klischeebild Hackathons. Das coole Wochenende, wo man sich trifft, von Mate lebt und 48 Stunden durchgehend programmiert. Und das kann natürlich sozusagen eine geile Party, ein Kreativrausch sein. Es gibt aber auch Kritik an diesem Format, die sagen, ist das nicht die Normalisierung von Crunchtime? Wenn in Firmen, die mit digitalen Produkten arbeiten, das trifft meistens, ich kenne es aus der Spielewelt, wo Spieleentwickler in dem unterworfen sind, wo man sagt, die müssen mehr arbeiten als die normale Arbeitszeit durchcrunchen, damit das Produkt schneller fertig wird. Und dann ist es halt, Schlaf ist überbewertet, nach Hause gehen ist überbewertet, Familie ist überbewertet. Und die Kritik an diesem Format ist, wenn man das so zelebriert, dieses, wie arbeitet es, 48 Stunden powern wir durch, ob das nicht einen falschen Grundstein liegt. Und ich finde ehrlich gesagt, ich bin mir da nicht so ganz schlüssig, welcher Seite oder welchem Argument ich da zugänglicher bin. Weil natürlich stelle ich mir vor, es ist eine tolle Erfahrung, wenn man eben so ein Wochenende durchmacht. Und zwar im Partysinn. Klar, man beschäftigt sich mit Themen, die aber dir interessieren, mit Leuten, die im besten Fall nett sind. Und dann braucht man halt nicht so viel Schlaf. Aber ich kann auch nachvollziehen, wenn jemand sagt, na ja, das normalisiert aber eben, dass Problemlösung geil und glamourös sein muss. Könnt ihr mir sagen, wo ihr da steht, wie ihr diese Diskussion seht? Fangen wir vielleicht mit Lilith an.
Ja, also ich finde, da muss man halt so ein bisschen unterscheiden. Also erst mal ist das natürlich ein totales Privileg, dass man sich diese 48 Stunden nehmen kann und dass man keine anderen Verpflichtungen hat und einfach mal so ein Wochenende so was durchackern kann. Und dann, finde ich, muss man unterscheiden zwischen, tue ich das gerade irgendwie für ein Unternehmen, tue ich das gerade irgendwie in einem komischen, kapitalistischen Konstrukt oder mache ich das irgendwie mit meinen Freunden und wir wollen zusammen was Cooles bauen. Und für mich ist das dann eigentlich nicht so viel anders als tatsächlich so auf eine Party gehen oder so. Nur irgendwie ein bisschen entspannter. Und das finde ich dann eigentlich ganz cool. Also es kommt für mich wirklich auf den Kontext an, in dem so ein Hackathon stattfindet.
Ich glaube für mich geht es vor allem um Sachen lernen und ich liebe es zu lernen. Ich finde es dann halt auch großartig, dass ich einfach dann in der Situation bin und sagen kann, gut, ich habe jetzt eben auch dieses Glück, diese 48 Stunden nichts anderes machen zu müssen. Finde ich eben auch das Schöne an Hackathons, dass ich mich nicht mal um solche Sachen wie Essen kümmern muss, sondern es irgendwann halt, hu, das Essen ist da. Und ich den Rest der Zeit einfach wirklich mit spannenden Menschen verbringen kann. Entweder über Themen reden oder halt tatsächlich tief in irgendeine Technik eintauchen. Und deswegen würde ich da auch sagen, ich nutze halt jede Minute einfach, weil es mich sehr glücklich macht und ich einfach Sachen lerne, was ich total toll finde und in dieser gewöhnlichen Form sonst nicht so einfach kriege.
Okay, Stefan? Ja, Lilith hat da gerade den ganz wichtigen Punkt gemacht mit der Zugehörigkeit. Weil das heißt nämlich andererseits auch wieder, wessen Blick da berücksichtigt wird. Und Crunch ist so, auf der einen Seite könnte ich genauso gut sagen, wenn ich mich mit meinen Freundinnen und Freunden treffe und am Wochenende endlich mal diesen Schrebergarten durchmache, dann wäre das ja theoretisch auch Crunch irgendwie, sonst irgendwas in der Richtung. Wo ich es aber auf jeden Fall sehe mit Crunch ist, es gibt ja auch Firmen-Hackathons, wo es dann darum geht, dass es dann ein Einstieg sein könnte, dass man sich bei der Firma bewirbt oder so was in der Richtung. Oder eben auch, dass sich so etabliert, wenn es da Hackathons mit großem Preisgeld gibt, dass Leute das so semi-professionell machen, von Hackathon zu Hackathon ziehen oder da ihre eigenen Produkte pitchen. Und das zahlt auf jeden Fall auf dieses Crunch-Bild ein. Aber ich nehme als generelle Ansage mit, das muss man ein bisschen differenzierter sehen. Und es geht tatsächlich um die Frage der Ausrichterin. Da wollte ich vielleicht tatsächlich dann da weitergehen mit diesem Firmen-Ding. Es gibt ja kein Konzept, was man nicht durch Kapitalismus pervertieren kann. Und ist das dann bei Firmen Hackathons also so... Ich überleg mir das gerade. Das klingt eigentlich total attraktiv. Weil ich lade mir übers Wochenende so ein paar Nerds ein und stelle denen so ein bisschen Mate und Essen hin. Und spare mir dann eine Design- oder Ideenabteilung in meiner Firma. Weil die pitchen dann halt nach 48 Stunden irgendwelche geilen Ideen. Da wird schon ein bisschen was irgendwie, wird schon ab und zu ein neues Produkt rumkommen. Wird das gemacht? Oder sehe ich das zu schwarz?
Also ich sehe tatsächlich, dass Firmen, Hackathons, wenn sie sich nach extern richten, dann gibt es das sehr häufig einfach als Bewerbermarketing. Also sprich, dass ich mir irgendwie Leute ranhole und dann sage ich, hey, das wird von diesen drei Firmen gesponsort. Es gibt diese tollen Preise. Das dann quasi die Kernintention eigentlich ist. Wir wollen irgendwie so Employer-Prending heißt das glaube ich, machen und wollen zeigen, was für ein cooles, hippes Unternehmen sind. Da gab es auch irgendwie so eine Welle. 2018, 2019 hatte ich den Eindruck, wo so ganz viele Unternehmen angefangen haben, dieses Konzept zu bringen bis hin zu Firmen, die nur noch solche Hackathon-Konzepte umsetzen. Und dann gibt es das Ganze halt noch gar nicht so selten firmintern, wo das dann halt wirklich so ein Innovations-Sprint einfach ist. Und ich meine, da kommt es halt drauf an, was die Firmenkultur ist. Wenn du eine Firmenkultur hast, wo du zwei Tage Hackathon machst, aber das bedeutet eigentlich, du kannst dir aussuchen, woran du arbeitest. Und du achtest trotzdem drauf, dass du keine 14 Stunden durcharbeitest. Dann ist das ja vielleicht auch ein cooles Format, um irgendwie Leute besser kennenzulernen und irgendwie zusammen an neuen Sachen zu arbeiten, die ihnen vielleicht interessieren. Aber das kann natürlich auch je nach Firmenkultur sehr toxisch sein.
Also ich hab tatsächlich schon von Hackathons gehört, aber auch schon erlebt, die eher in einem Firmenkontext stattfanden. Und das Problem, das riesige Problem an der Geschichte ist halt, macht man am Ende einen Wettbewerb? In den meisten Fällen ja. Und wer bewertet dann die Ergebnisse und Produkte, die rausgekommen sind? Meistens irgendeine Jury, wo Menschen mit hohen Titeln drin sitzen. Das sind vielleicht nicht unbedingt die geeignetsten, die die technische Komponente davon beurteilen können. Und wenn dann noch sowas wie Innovation mitbewertet wird, wird es besonders witzig, weil man dann halt immer wieder merkt, die Projekte, die ich von Jungtag kenne, werden hier in einem größeren Rahmen mit einer niedrigeren tatsächlichen Umsetzung, nämlich einfach nur, ich habe eine schöne Präsentation vorgestellt, und werden dann mit ganz besonderem Innovationsgrad gelobt, wo ich mich immer frage, ich glaube, ihr werdet hinterher richtig damit auf die Nase fallen, einfach, weil ihr euch nicht damit beschäftigt habt, was es eigentlich schon gibt und was wirklich neue Ideen sind. Die dann auch ein bisschen tragfähiger sind als das, was manche Menschen in 48 Stunden hinkriegen können.
Also die Kritik wäre, wenn man das macht, dann produziert man Gassenglänzer, also Dinge, die irgendwie schön aussehen.
Auf jeden Fall.
Ich finde das ganz interessant, weil in der Geschichte von Jugend Hackt ist es ja so gewesen, dass die am Anfang tatsächlich auch eine Jury hatten, also in den ersten Jahren, und das aber aufgehört haben. Mit der Argumentation, das macht ja sozusagen, das schafft eine Ungleichheit, die die dann einfach nicht wollen. Und ich frage mich, ob das überhaupt sinnvoll ist, sozusagen etwas zu bewerten oder auszuzeichnen. Weil ja, wenn ich euch bis jetzt richtig verstanden habe, ist das Tolle an einem Hackathon ja, dass man eben Dinge ausprobieren kann. Und dann, im Prinzip genau wie Julia gerade gesagt hat, ist es ja, wenn man eine Auszeichnung macht, dann senkt man vielleicht die Motivation, einfach Dinge auszuprobieren. Oder?
Oder wirklich was umzusetzen, was ja auch schiefgehen kann. Während wenn ich eine Fernsehpräsentation oder im Online-Format ein schickes Video mache, sieht es immer gut aus.
Also es gibt ja auch Firmen, die da drauf aufgesprungen sind nach dem Motto, das ist offenbar was, was hip ist. Und wir möchten auch hip sein. Und deswegen müssen wir jetzt ein Hackathon machen. Und dann nimmt man eben das Format, so wie man halt das mitbekommt in den entsprechenden Kreisen.
Und genauso gibt es andere Firmen, die denken, ich habe eine Geschäftsidee und ich möchte jetzt was gründen. Ich kriege das aber alleine nicht hin und gehe jetzt mal zu einem Hackathon, um dort die richtigen Menschen kennenzulernen, dass ich denen mein Projekt vorstellen kann.
Was nicht schlechtes sein muss. Da ist eine spannende Frage, die Ideen, die da gehabt werden, die kann jeder mitnehmen, oder? Prinzipiell ja. Die Originalität ist ja wieder das Problem. Meistens waren die ja schon irgendwo. Wenn du halt so einen Web-Verbs-Charakter hast oder wenn dann Leute sagen, das ist jetzt meins, dann hast du da ein Problem. Ich glaube, Lilith, da kannst du doch jetzt direkt was erzählen dazu, oder?
Ja, witzige Geschichte. Ich arbeite seit einem Dreivierteljahr daran, dass ich versuche, ein möglichst sicheres und offenes Konzept zu entwickeln, wie Behörden sich selbst digitalisieren können, indem sie das Online-Zugangsgesetz umsetzen. Da geht es darum, dass in einer IT-Abteilung von einer Behörde sich das Tool Formularium, was quasi so ein Formulargenerator ist, nehmen können und nach den offenen Behördenstandards Formulare bauen können. Das mache ich Open Source und in meiner Freizeit und mittlerweile in Kooperation mit einigen Behörden. Alle haben Bock drauf und das ist ganz cool. Jetzt war letztens vor einer Woche der Update Deutschland Hackathon. Es gab zwei Teams, die sich mit genau demselben Problem beschäftigt haben, die sich vorher, so wie ich es mitbekommen habe, nicht diesen Problem-Space angeschaut haben, mit was muss ich eigentlich beachten, wenn ich was für die öffentliche Verwaltung baue, welche Standards gibt es da, was gibt es da schon für Vorarbeiten und so weiter und so fort, sondern sich hingesetzt haben und gesagt haben, an einem Wochenende lösen wir das Problem Online-Interaktion zwischen Verwaltung und BürgerInnen und dann halt einen Versuchsträger gebaut haben, der aber halt niemandem was hilft, weil sie halt überhaupt nicht Rücksicht darauf genommen haben, was müsste man eigentlich beachten. Und eigentlich arbeitet dies schon so, zumindest wenn ich mir den Markt angeschaut habe, dreimal gemacht wurde in unterschiedlichen Formen, da halt einfach noch mal gemacht wird. Ich sage jetzt nicht, dass das wertlos ist. Alle Menschen, die dabei waren, haben bestimmt Erkenntnisse daraus gezogen. Und ich meine, wenn man das auswertet, findet man am Ende bestimmt noch irgendwelche interessanten Erkenntnisse. Aber dieses Not invented here-Syndrom ist eine Sache, die ganz häufig auf Hackathons auftritt. Da habe ich es mal ganz konkret erlebt, wo ich dann auch versucht habe, mit den Teilnehmenden Kontakt aufzunehmen. Und dann waren sie so, ja, nee, wir wollen das hier schon nochmal neu machen. Uns interessieren jetzt hier die Standards nicht.
Aber ja. Das klingt so, als ob, also Hackathons als Hort der Innovation funktionieren kann, aber eben auch tatsächlich gar nicht muss. Weil wir jetzt schon dabei sind, Update Deutschland. Weil jetzt unweigerlich noch zwei Begriffe fallen werden, vermute ich, es ist nur eine Vermutung, hätte ich gern, dass die jemand von euch erklärt. Der erste ist Civic Tech. Was ist Civic Tech? Stefan, weißt du doch bestimmt, oder? Hast du bestimmt mit zu tun? Ja, das ist wieder so ein magischer Begriff, der alles in nix sagt. Du hast ihn als erster verwendet heute. Ja, ich weiß. Das ist wirklich ein Problem. In der ganzen Debatte sind es ganz viele Begriffe, die Projektionsflächen sind. Civic Tech, könnte man vielleicht sagen, das sind Menschen, die finden irgendwas vor in ihrer Umwelt, vor allem im Umgang mit öffentlichen Stellen, Behörden und so weiter, und denken sich, mein Gott, das muss man doch anders machen können. Also wie die Automechanikerin, die auf dem Weihfahrer sitzt, mitfährt und das Klopfen aus dem Motorraum hört und dacht, mach 800 Meter und dich unter Waffengewalt rechts ranfahren lässt, um sie das mal anzugucken. Und das heißt, die gehen damit um, die schauen sich an, wie sehen die Dienste aus, wie sehen die Daten aus und warum kann man da nicht mehr davon offen haben. Und ja, wir gehen da in der Freizeit in einen Austausch mit Behörden, machen Prototypen und hätten das gerne anders und würden sich gerne mit anderen Dingen beschäftigen, weil das dann die Behörden selber wieder übernehmen. Also Civic Tech ist eine Art von Aktivismus? Und Open Data ist dann sozusagen das, was hinten dranfällt, nämlich, wenn man Civic Tech machen will, also Behörden digital zugänglich machen müssen, die Daten, die die Behörden verwenden, offen sein? Genau. Open Data, also offene Daten, sind Daten der öffentlichen Hand, die für jedermann und jede Frau und alle Menschen überhaupt zu jedwegen Zwecken, egal welcher Art, frei zur Verfügung gestellt werden. Und das ist ein Ideal oder das ist die Realität? Das gibt es schon an ganz vielen Stellen. Also müsste es noch viel mehr geben. Das hängt meistens nicht am Willen, sondern an der Umsetzungsfähigkeit. Aber es gibt ja auch offene Daten, die nicht von Behörden kommen. Vickidata ist vorhin schon genannt worden. Das ist die größte Sammlung offener Daten, die zu jedem Zweck nachgenutzt werden können. Die begegnen an relativ vielen Stellen tatsächlich. Okay, wenn wir das haben, können wir jetzt über den aktuellen Anlass sprechen. Update Deutschland. Was genau ist das eigentlich? Wer hat da Idee gehabt, da was zu machen? Oh je, wer sagt jetzt dazu was? Ist das Entsetze schweigen oder sich nicht vordrängeln wollen?
Ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht, wie es genau entstanden ist. Deswegen tue ich mich gerade so ein bisschen schwer, weil wenn ich nur so halbe Sachen weiß, dann sage ich am liebsten gar nichts. Alles was ich aber weiß, ist, dass es organisiert wurde von Project Together und Next Coder. Project Together war auch eines der Unternehmen, ich glaube es ist eine gemeinnützige GmbH, die wir versus Virus mit organisiert haben. Also den großen Hackathon von 2020. Weil das ja so super lief und da ja so tolle Sachen rausgekommen sind.
Warte, ich muss kurz hören, meine Kolleginnen sagen immer, Ironie im Radio funktioniert nicht.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, das war jetzt ganz bewusst ein bisschen ironisch gesprochen. Auf jeden Fall haben die deswegen nochmal einen Hackathon organisiert unter der Schirmherrschaft des Bundeskanzleramts. Finanziert wurde das allerdings nicht von der öffentlichen Hand, sondern von verschiedenen Stiftungen. Und wer da genau jetzt wen beauftragt hat, das weiß ich dahinter nicht.
Und was war das Ziel?
Vielleicht noch ganz kurz. Finanziert wurde es durch die Bertelsmann Stiftung, die Robert-Bosch Stiftung und die Stiftung Mercatron, um das korrekt zu haben. Und das Ziel war Update Deutschland. Also versuchen, ich zitiere das vielleicht einfach am einfachsten mal von der Webseite, auf mehreren Ebenen gesellschaftliche Wirkung entfalten, indem durch eine digitale Plattform unterstützte Community es BürgerInnen in ganz Deutschland ermöglicht, innovative Lösungen für gesellschaftliche Zukunftsfragen zu entwickeln, zu testen und breitflächig umzusetzen. Da merkt man schon sehr viel Marketingsprech, was Stefan schon vorhin gesagt hat. Die können halt nur wissen, was sie sagen, was sie wollen. Was sie tatsächlich wollen, ist noch mal eine andere Frage. Aber es sollten irgendwie gesellschaftliche Fragen gelöst werden. Irgendwie mit Technik dabei. Oder auf jeden Fall über eine technische Plattform oder so.
Ja, ich kann da vielleicht mal anschließen. Letztes Jahr war der große Virus-Hackathon. Was für viele Menschen, die IT machen und vier Wochen auf dem Hintern saßen, so ein Outlet war, zu sagen, jetzt mach ich mal was und trag was zur Lösung der Lage bei. Zumindest mal das Gefühl dazu haben. Das war auch im Nachklang von der Veranstaltung. Sie waren alle sehr zufrieden und selbstlobend und so weiter. Da klang auch schon an, dass sie da eine Wiederholung dessen machen wollten. Was dann letzten Dezember und diesen Januar rauskam, ist, dass sie sich diesmal vorrangig an Kommunen, viel an Kommunen, sich gewendet haben. Die hatten den Deutschen Städtetag, das ist so ein Dachverband. Hatten sie da auch relativ früh als Partner mit an Bord, so wie ich das mitbekommen habe. Sie haben dann verschiedene Landkreisestädte, aber eben auch so Sozialverbände, wie zum Beispiel Caritas-Verband und so was in der Richtung. Haben sie eben angesprochen, ob sie da Challenges, also solche Fragestellungen einfach einreichen wollen, die man dann im Lauf dieses Wochenendes bearbeiten darf, wenn man da dann teilgenommen hat? Wir müssen gleich mal zurückkommen, weil es jetzt immer referenziert, wir versus Virus war noch mal was. Weil ehrlich gesagt ist mir das über den Weg gelaufen. Aber ich hab nie irgendwas, was da rauskommen gehört. Das Ziel war doch something something Corona digitale Lösung? Oder was sollte da passieren?
Ganz genau. In einem Wochenende die Corona-Krise lösen, war so ein bisschen deren Pitch. Und die haben das, glaube ich, tatsächlich auch die Gruppe, die das letztes Jahr organisiert hat. Also unter anderem Project Together, aber auch ein paar andere Organisationen haben innerhalb von einer Woche, als Corona so losging, gesagt, wir machen jetzt einen Hackathon. Und haben dann eine Woche lang einen Hackathon gemacht. Und danach haben sie ein paar der Lösungen tatsächlich weiter gefördert.
Also das war halt nach einem Vorbild. Es gab in Estland auch kurz vorher eine ähnliche Veranstaltung. Und sie dachten dann, oder ihre Idee war dann, das zu transferieren nach Deutschland. Und ist dabei was rumgekommen? Es waren relativ viele Projekte. Also ich habe dieser Tage nochmal nachgeforscht, wie viel das war. Es waren also dann schon, also sie haben ja mit 40.000 angemeldet oder sowas geworben. Und es sind aber schon einige Projekte auch dann hinterher, da gab es eine Übersicht auf sein Post, die dann da rausgekommen sind, die bearbeitet worden sind. Und es sind dann tatsächlich im Nachklang auch einige Projekte begleitet worden, haben Förderungen bekommen, dass man die irgendwie noch weiter ausbaut tatsächlich. Förderungen von den Bosch, Mercator, was auch immer? Nein, nein, das war jetzt in dem Fall anders tatsächlich. Das war so, dass es dann einen Konstrukt gibt, den Prototype Fund, das ist ein Projekt von der Open Knowledge Foundation, die eigentlich freie Open-Source-Software fördern. Die werden da, die kriegen Gelder vom, es korrigiert mich glaubt vom BMWF, wenn ich mich nicht ganz arg täusche. Und die verteilen das unter auf Projekte, die sich bewerben. Zu einem bestimmten Thema gibt es dann öfter mal so Ausschreibungen. Dann kann man sich dann bewerben drauf und dann werden die Gelder verteilt. Und über dieses Konstrukt konnten sich dann eben relativ kurz danach, weil da auch dann Kritik kam, von wegen das ein Wochenende reicht ja nicht. Das muss man ja auch dann verstetigen. Über das Konstrukt wurden dann an Ausgewählte von den Projekten wurde auch Förderung verteilt. Ich bin gar nicht ganz sicher, wie man jetzt weitermacht. Bei dem Wir vs. Virus, also ich find's, ich find's eben so ein bisschen komisch und sehr, sehr aktionistisch. Aber andererseits, wer weiß, vielleicht ist dabei was rumgekommen oder hat sozusagen zumindest den Leuten denn Ventil in der Zeit gegeben. Bei dem Update Deutschland, das klingt für mich so ein bisschen nach Beschäftigungstherapie. Also ihr habt jetzt gerade schon gesagt, man kann nur sagen, was die sagen. Und man kann aber auch interpretieren und vermuten, was ist denn eure Spekulation, was damit erreicht werden soll? Also wie würdet ihr das denn interpretieren?
Es ist einfach, glaube ich, sehr, sehr schwierig, weil wenn man sich diese Herausforderungen oder diese Challenges anschaut, und ich glaube, deswegen habe ich gerade so stark betont, dass es eben von Stiftungen finanziert wurde, dann hat da zum Beispiel eine Stadt eingereicht, die Frage, wie man denn die Services der Verwaltung nach Corona so schnell wie möglich komplett digital anbieten könne. Und ich denke mir so, irgendwas klingelt da bei mir. Gibt es da nicht irgendwelche gesetzlichen Vorschriften, dass man sich darum kümmern muss? Oder wie können wir kulturelle Teilhabe im ländlichen Raum zukünftig gewährleisten? War eine andere Frage aus einem Landesministerium, wo ich mir denke, das sind für mich hochpolitische, gesellschaftliche Fragen, wo ich gar nicht möchte, dass irgendjemand in 48 Stunden eine Lösung anbietet. Weil ich behaupte, das geht gar nicht. Das muss man doch irgendwo ausdiskutieren.
Aber ich finde, das ist ein interessanter Widerspruch zu dem, was ich bis jetzt gelernt habe. Wenn es heißen würde, ich will nicht, dass in den 48 Stunden eine Lösung erstellt und dann umge- sozusagen, und dann ist es das, die einzig, die noch gelten kann. Das kann ich verstehen. Aber wenn man Hackathons als Kreativitätswerkzeug sagt, na ja, im Prinzip müssten wir, und es ist ein lang anhaltendes Problem, es bedarf auch einer demokratischen, aber wir kommen halt einfach keine gute Idee, könnt ihr da mal drüber nachdenken? Ist das nicht genau das, wofür so Sachen gemacht worden sind?
Wenn die Voraussetzung ist, dass es noch keine Ideen gibt.
Genau, ich glaube, das ist genau der Punkt. Wenn wir auf der grünen Wiese jetzt anfangen würden, und die letzten 12 Jahre Civic Tech hätten nie stattgefunden, dann fände ich das okay. Aber gerade weil es nach letztem Jahr nach Virus so viel Debatte gab über dieses, es gibt da schon Initiativen, die sich halt Jahren mit beschäftigen, und ihr habt nichts davon aufgegriffen, nichts versucht aufzugreifen und zu schauen, warum die Sachen nicht funktioniert haben, dann ist es schon ein bisschen eigerlich, dass nach dem ganzen Jahr Debatte immer noch so getan wird, als könne man alles neu anfangen.
Dazu fällt mir ein gutes Beispiel ein, was ich nämlich gestern gefunden habe. Gestern wurde ich gebeten von einem Bekannten, der in Leipzig gerne die Spielplätze hätte, weil er die für ein Uni-Projekt brauchte. Und ich meinte so, Leipzig hat doch Open Data, kann man mal nachschauen. Und tatsächlich habe ich gesehen, dass es diesen Datensatz in der Form nicht wirklich maschinenlesbar gab, sondern nur auf ganz vielen Unterwebsites. Und dann wurde ich darauf hingewiesen, wiederum von anderen Menschen, dass das schon mal vor 7 Jahren, also 2014, gemacht wurde von der Zivilgesellschaft, die das auch gesehen hat, ist nicht maschinenlesbar da. Machen wir maschinenlesbar, weil offensichtlich braucht das jemand. Und bis heute wird es nicht von der Stadt selbst bereitgestellt. Also ich glaube, das ist ein ganz gutes Beispiel, wo es einfach zeigt, Menschen brauchen immer mal wieder was. Und es gibt es einfach nicht. Und das gibt es auch nicht nach 7 Jahren, nachdem Zivilgesellschaft schon gezeigt hat, wie es gehen müsste. Und davon gibt es Beispiele wie Sand am Meer.
Ja, das zieht sich komplett durch eigentlich. Also ich bin mir noch nicht ganz sicher, was das mit dem Hackathon-Thema zu tun hat, weil die Voraussetzungen bzw. die Forderungen, dass es viel mehr, also Data und Open Data und Schnittstellen, gerade was staatliche Institutionen angeht, die gibt es schon tatsächlich seit Langem. Oder ich versuche zusammen herauszufinden, warum das jetzt gerade hier zusammenhängt. Und von dem, was ihr sagt, also na ja, einem Hackathon die Aufgabe zu geben, denkt euch da mal was aus und so tun, als gäbe es noch nichts. Okay, kann ich als Kritik verstehen. Andererseits habt ihr vorhin auch gesagt, ein Hackathon kann auch dazu dienen, dass Leute, die eh schon an dem Thema arbeiten, dahin kommen und sich nochmal präsentieren und Mitstreiterinnen suchen können. Das wäre doch dann genau die Anwendung für so ein Update Deutschland, oder? Dass alle Leute, die sagen, hier, wir betreiben diese Open-Data-Schnittstelle schon seit tausend Jahren und sie ist wirklich sehr, sehr gut, schaut sie euch an, dass das dann genau die Bühne sein kann.
Ja, genau, das ist aber ja so nicht passiert.
Aha, warum?
Also was ja passiert ist, ist, man hat gesagt, Kommunen und wer auch immer, die dürfen Ideen einreichen und dann dürfen andere Menschen dahin kommen und sich mit diesen Problemen beschäftigen. Man ist aber nie von dieser Perspektive ausgegangen. Was gibt es denn schon? Wen können wir denn so von Initiativen, die irgendwie schon Sachen umsetzen, einladen und können dann schauen, was wir damit weitermachen können? Sondern es ist ja immer von dieser Perspektive ausgegangen. XY hat ein Problem und das ist dann häufig ein so gesellschaftliches Problem gewesen, dass ich mir dachte, das gehört wirklich nicht auf einen Hackathon, weil da für die Leute gar nicht da sind. Wir können nicht alle Probleme technokratisch lösen, aber das ist vielleicht ein anderes Problem. Und dann durften Leute da diese Probleme lösen und dadurch sind natürlich nicht die richtigen Leute, die sich mit dem Thema schon beschäftigt haben, zusammengekommen.
Also mir scheint es hier irgendwie so drei Wege zu geben, die wir jetzt noch behandeln müssten. Das eine ist, dass ich tatsächlich diese Eindruck habe, dass eine Sache, die ihr anprangert, ist, diese Hackathons werden benutzt in einer Art und Weise, wo das Wichtige, nämlich die Kreativität, gar nicht so sehr stattfinden kann. Weil das sozusagen, dadurch, dass die Städte, Länder und Kommunen ihre Fragen und ihre Probleme da rein geben, dass eher so eine Art Markt ist, als tatsächlich was Kreatives. Das andere ist tatsächlich die Frage, ob Hackathons dieses, man kann alle Dinge mit einer Software lösen, irgendwie als so Geisteshaltung vielleicht zu sehr vortreibt. Und das dritte, und da können wir vielleicht am Abschluss drüber reden, ist die Frage, also gibt es einfach Situationen, wo Hackathons vielleicht nicht so gut ist, wie unterscheidet man gute von schlechten? Und ich würde mich jetzt erstmal der ersten widmen wollen. Also ist sozusagen ein Problem, also dass man eigentlich keinen Hackathon bräuchte, sondern eine Kreativwerkstatt, die überhaupt erst mal aufzeigt, was sind denn die Probleme? Wie formuliert man die denn? Also dass man die Zielsetzung gar nicht so weit vorgibt oder anders gestaltet?
Genau, gerade wenn ich gesellschaftliche Probleme lösen möchte, dann würde ich ja viel eher sagen, ich hole mir irgendwie einen möglichst breiten Schnitt durch die Gesellschaft an den Tisch oder in irgendein Format und arbeite dann mit denen gemeinsam daran, wie man gesellschaftliche Probleme lösen kann. Und macht das dann natürlich so divers, wie unsere gesamte Gesellschaft auch ist. Und dann kommen da vielleicht auch richtig gute Ideen raus, bei denen man auch wirklich alle Leute berücksichtigt, die es in unserer Gesellschaft gibt. Und nicht nur Menschen, die meistens relativ privilegiert sind, weil sie an so einem Hackathon teilnehmen können.
Und schon auch sozusagen in der Richtung, eigentlich müsste das Ziel sein, liebe Leute, sagt uns mal, was die dringendsten Probleme sind. Und dann findet ihr oder vielleicht wir zusammen in dem Wochenende raus, wie das Lösungsansatz sein könnte, statt zu sagen, hier ist Problem X, Y und Z, macht mal. Ich finde, das Format ist schon falsch für die Fragestellung. Aha, warum? Also eigentlich, wenn man sagt, ich möchte bei dem Hackathon rausfinden, was man machen könnte, das ist durchgespielt. Inwiefern? Die Hackathons gab es ja schon. Wir sind jetzt vom Stand. Eigentlich sind wir auf 2015 zurückkatapultiert worden durch das ganze Jahr wie evtl. das Virus. Es gab schon genügend Hackathons, die genau das behandelt haben, von wegen, was könnte man eigentlich tun, gerade gegenüber der öffentlichen Hand. Theoretisch reicht es ja, in den kompletten Schatz von Jugendakt reinzuschauen, was die Jugendlichen sich da ausgedacht haben. Nur um mal rauszufinden, was könnte man eigentlich tun. Da gibt es genügend Beispiele. Meistens ist es aber so, das scheitert nicht daran, dass dann dieses Produkt fertig gemacht werden müsste oder man die Fördergießkanne ausgießt, sondern dass diejenigen, die offene Daten bereitstellen sollen, dass diejenigen, die zum Beispiel ihre Dienste online zugänglich machen sollten, dass die das nicht tun. Und dass die es auch meistens gar nicht machen können, weil sie die Strukturen selber nicht haben. Also gerade die öffentliche Hand. Das heißt, wir haben jetzt gerade einen Hackathon, der den Eindruck erweckt, dass die öffentliche Hand gerade ganz innovativ ist und richtig so auf dem Puls der Zeit entlangschwimmt. Ihnen hat nur der Input von außen gefehlt, während eigentlich die Problematik im eigenen Haus drin liegt und auch schon Generationen von Ehrenamtlichen, die Jahre vorher an diesen Klippen, die die intern haben, zerschellt sind. Und da könnte man auch schon fast sagen, das ist eigentlich unverschämend, jetzt noch mal eine neue Generation einzuladen, die jetzt an denselben Klippen zerschellen soll. Also ich tue mich gerade ein bisschen schwer. Das hätte ich gerne noch mal ein bisschen differenzierter. Weil ich fand das ganz eindrücklich, wie Julia erzählt hat, auch aus dem eigenen Erleben, dass es nie gelegen hat, um irgendwo hinzukommen und auch was zu lernen. Und da würde ich sagen, wenn du Hackathon durchgespielt sagst, meinst du dann, die sind durchgespielt in dem Sinne, dass sie momentan eher ein Feigenblatt für fehlende Innovationen sind, indem man so tut, als gäbe es noch keine Lösung. Aber du meinst, vermute ich jetzt nicht, durchgespielt in dem Sinne von, dass nicht jede Generation für sich dieses Format auch für dieses Thema entdecken können soll. Ich glaube, da können wir unterscheiden zwischen der Perspektive Teilnehmende und Veranstaltende und Ausflugobende. Ich finde es immer okay und immer cool, wenn Leute zu Hackathons gehen mit dem Ziel, ich möchte was dazulernen. Da ist überhaupt nichts schlecht zu reden davon. Ich finde es eher jetzt in dem Moment problematisch, wenn den Teilnehmenden dann der Eindruck vermittelt wird, sie könnten mit ihren Ideen tatsächlich jetzt auch, gerade gegenüber der öffentlichen Hand, jetzt Mords was verändern und Mords was tun. Gerade weil so viele vorher schon gescheitert sind. Und es geht ja nicht um Innovation eigentlich. Wir haben ja eigentlich nie ein Innovationsproblem oder ein Ideenfindungsproblem, weil viele Ideen sind schon gefunden, sondern wir haben Vollzug- und Umsetzungsproblem.
Und der Witz ist ja, um was dazu zu lernen, muss man halt anwesend sein. Und ich glaube tatsächlich, dass es total helfen würde, wenn die Menschen, die die Fragen stellen, auch wirklich vor Ort sind, rumlaufen, mit Menschen sich austauschen auf der einen Seite. Und auch das nur sehr eingeschränkt, weil ich glaube, ich habe relativ wenige Hemmungen, irgendwo hinzugehen und zu sagen, Hi, ich bin Julia, ich hab keinen Plan, erklärt mir mal, was ihr hier macht. Das ist aber für viele andere eine riesige Hürde, überhaupt zu so einer Veranstaltung zu gehen. Ich denke mir so, ich bin auch 1, 83 und ich habe auch kein Problem, obwohl ich jetzt weiblich gelesen bin, mich neben irgendwelche Typen zu stellen und sie halt mit meinen Fragen zu löchern. Viele andere haben da aber ein riesiges Problem damit. Es gibt einfach ganz große strukturelle Probleme. Das ist keine Kultur, in der man sich vielleicht unbedingt direkt wohl und ernst genommen fühlt. Viele werden dann solche Sachen gefragt wie ach, von wem bist du denn die Freundin? Oder so. Also schon allein jetzt auf dieser Geschlechter-Ebene. Und da gibt es noch so viele mehr, die auch da einfach wahnsinnige Hürden aufbauen, weshalb auch auf solchen Veranstaltungen gar nicht alle überhaupt rumlaufen. Und man kann zwar Sachen lernen, aber halt doch nur sehr beschränkt. Also ich würde mir wünschen, dass die Menschen, die was lernen könnten, mehr da sind. Aber man halt auch sieht, das ist nur ein sehr starker Eindruck. Und dann muss man vielleicht auch die Menschen, die dann da sind und ihre Probleme vorbringen, die auch ernst nehmen. Das passiert auch öfter nicht.
Im Prinzip ist sehr gut nachvollziehbar, was du sagst. Aber ist das jetzt eine Kritik an Update Deutschland und ähnlichen Veranstaltungen oder eine Kritik oder etwas sozusagen, worauf man generell als Hackathon-Veranstalterin achten sollte?
Ich glaube, man muss generell drauf achten, aber ganz besonders, wenn man es mit diesen absolut, wie ich finde, überhöhten Anspruch wie Update Deutschland macht.
Ja, und ich mein, da kommt bei Update Deutschland ja noch hinzu, dass es halt überhaupt nicht so vermarktet wird. Du kannst da einfach hinkommen, du kannst da was lernen, du kannst da einfach auch, wenn du nicht so viel Ahnung hast, an Sachen mitarbeiten, sondern das wird dir mehr so vermarktet mit, wie machen wir jetzt hier ganz große Innovationen? Als ich letztes Jahr mir das alles so angestatt habe, da dachte ich, da hätten irgendwie so die 2017er angerufen und die CDU hätte Innovationsmarketing gefunden, weil ja mehrere Bundesministerinnen und dieses Jahr glaube ich sogar die Frau Bundeskanzlerin selbst die Schirmherrschaft dafür übernommen haben und dann da reden gehalten haben. Und ich habe letztes Jahr ein halbes Jahr im BMWF gearbeitet und habe dadurch zufällig irgendwie einen Konflikt zwischen Karliczek und Dorubert mitbekommen, wer denn die Schirmherrschaft für wir für Schulen einen weiteren Hackathon, der aus wir versus Virus raus oder zumindest aus der Zeit raus entstanden ist, übernimmt. Und da hat man so gemerkt, ja, die sind halt 100% aus einer Marketingperspektive für sich selbst, dass sie irgendwie innovativ sind. Und genau dasselbe passiert halt auch aus Sicht von diesen Anbieterinnen, von diesen Hackathons, wie zum Beispiel Project Together. Die das halt wirklich als was total Großes vermarkten. Und eigentlich wäre es glaube ich viel besser, es viel niedrigschwelliger zu vermarkten. Und also wenn man so ein Format in irgendeiner Form machen möchte, dann ist es halt wirklich nicht der Innovationsaspekt, sondern halt vielleicht ein Lernaspekt.
Also das klingt mir immer mehr so als Hackathon als Format, gut und schön, aber in dieser Situation ist es wirklich sozusagen fast schon ein Missbrauch, weil es eigentlich alles andere ist, als das, was grundsätzlich die Idee dahinter war. Ich will noch sozusagen eine Perspektive oder eine Anekdote, nee, andersrum, eine Anekdote, die mir versprochen wurde, die ihr mir heute vielleicht erzählt. Und zwar gibt es, ich weiß gar nicht, ob das jetzt neben Update Deutschland ist ja quasi noch im Lauf, das muss ja letztes Jahr gewesen sein, eine App, die sozusagen ethisch sehr bedenklich war. Wissen Sie, worauf ich anspiele? Ja. Kannst du das kurz erklären, was da passiert ist? Soll ich oder kann es jemand besser? Ich weiß es nicht. Also es sind zwei Sachen passiert eigentlich, wo klar wird, glaube ich, dass die Frage immer ist, mit welchem Ziel macht man das und was ist eigentlich die Utopie, auf die man hinarbeitet? Es gab zwei Dinge. Zum einen gab es ein Team, das schon im Rahmen des Hackathons gesagt hat, wir möchten eigentlich eine Seite machen für... Bei Wir vs. Virus, genau. Die für asiatisch gelesene Menschen in Deutschland praktische Vernetzung und Selbsthilfe im Endeffekt untereinander anbieten soll. Das war so unter dem Namen Ich Bin Kein Virus. Victoria Kurevue war da eine von den Beteiligten. Einfach von wegen anti-asiatischen Rassismus, im Sinne von du wirst auf der Straße mindestens komisch beäugt. Oder es gibt abfallige Kommentare, Menschen sind auch angespuckt worden auf offener Straße, weil dieses Virus mit Asien verbunden worden ist. Und alle, die asiatisch aussahen, wirklich im Alltag darunter zu leiden hatten an der Stelle. Was im Nachhinein klar wurde, ist, das Programm wurde nicht für die Weiterförderung ausgesucht. Eine der Protagonisten hat den offenen Austausch mit den Organisatoren gesucht. Und kein Feedback, was sie bekommen hat, ist, das sei alles durch eine Jury geprüft worden. Und sie wissen gar nicht, ob es so was wie antiasiatischen Rassismus gibt. Was? Was? So sinngemäß. Die anderen korrigierten mich. Ihr wart damals bei den Twitter-Diskussionen, habt ihr mitgelesen. Das ist auch öffentlich nachlesbar. Das kann man nachvollziehen. Also in die Richtung ging das Ganze dann. Die Beteiligten haben das dann über Crowdfunding zum Teil gemacht und auch selber das Ding umzusetzen. Und die Seite gibt es auch tatsächlich noch. ichbinkeinvirus.org ist es, wenn ich mich nicht ganz abtäusche. Genau. Das ist ein Netzwerk. Die haben praktisch schon einen Netzwerk gebaut an dem Endeffekt, wo man sich allein schon, um auch zu zeigen, es gibt andere, denen es auch so geht, wo man an Erfahrungsberichte austauschen kann. Ich muss noch mal festhalten, weil die Argumentation, das Projekt nicht auszuwählen war, es wäre gar nicht klar, ob es anti-asiatischen Rassismus gibt. Das war sinngemäß ein Argument. Und ein anderes war, dass die Jury ja diverse sei, weil ja auch ein Mensch in der Jury sei, der im Rollstuhl sitzt.
Genau. Und im Nachhinein gab es dann noch das Argument, als ihnen aufgefallen ist, dass das nicht so klug war, war das nächste Argument, dass das ja technisch überhaupt nicht anspruchsvoll und interessant sei, weil sie ja nur eine Wordpress-Seite gebaut haben.
Ich lass das einfach mal so stehen. Das ist ja...
Besonders fatal an der Geschichte natürlich auch der Abschluss, dass nämlich die Abschlusspräsentation quasi der einzelnen Ergebnisse dieses Hackathons in einem Video auf YouTube hochgeladen werden mussten und die Kommentare haben gezeigt, dass es doch recht starken anti-asiatischen Rassismus in Deutschland gibt. Und damit musste das Team alleine klarkommen und haben wenig bis gar keine Unterstützung von den OrganisatorInnen bekommen.
Also ich bin nämlich nicht 100% sicher, das kann sein, dass ich hörte davon, dass irgendwo ein Anwalt beauftragt worden sei, keine Ahnung was wie. Aber öffentlich lesbar ist halt nicht sonderlich viel davon. Aber ich kenn ja sozusagen von Hackathons, wo ich dabei war, tatsächlich nur Jugendhackt. Und ich habe die VeranstalterInnen immer so erlebt, dass eines der ganz großen Sachen da ist, dass das ein Safe Space ist. Also sowohl nach innen für die TeilnehmerInnen untereinander, als auch, dass sichergestellt wird, dass davon aus, was ich persönlich habe. Und mal abgesehen davon, dass ich persönlich das Verhalten absolut von Virus beziehungsweise den VeranstalterInnen indiskutabel finde, ist es zu vielverlangt zu sagen, also wenn ihr schon so ein großes Ding macht und dann auch noch so tut, als würde das sozusagen was für die Gesellschaft bringen, dass nicht da die Verantwortung liegt, um genau so was aufzufangen?
Das war auch die allgemeine Kritik. Also ich sehe das auch ganz genauso. Was so zurückgespielt wurde von den Leuten, die das damals organisiert haben, war ja, ja, wir haben das ja auch nur in unserer Freizeit gemacht, was natürlich totaler Quatsch ist, weil sie größtenteils irgendwie schon das auch beruflich machen oder zumindest in demselben Kontext. Und naja, wenn man irgendwie sagt, man macht eine Veranstaltung in dieser Größe, natürlich müsste man erwarten, dass sich die VeranstalterInnen darum kümmern.
Also ich glaube, die wurden auch von dem Andrang, der da kam, gerade eben auch aus dieser Perspektive raus, ich kann jetzt was tun, wurden die glaube ich auch komplett überrollt. Also die mussten auch glaube ich den CEO von Slack irgendwie auf Twitter anhauen, dass der die ganzen Menschen in ihren Slack-Kanal reinbringen kann, weil sie halt nicht irgendwie 18.000 Leute auf einmal in Slack einladen konnten. Okay, trotzdem keine Entschuldigung. Gerade wenn es im Nachhinein auch nicht so sagen besser geworden ist. Was war die andere Geschichte? Will ich die überhaupt noch hören? Hab ich noch genug Platz auf meiner Stimme für einen weiteren Facepalm? Ja. Lilith, komm, mach du mal.
Ja, also stell dir vor, du hast das Problem, du möchtest obdachlosen Menschen Geld geben. Und stell dir vor, du hast das Problem von, du möchtest eine Stadt sauber machen. Und jetzt machst du einen Hackathon, brainstorming und bringst das zusammen. Was wäre die schlechteste Idee, die dir dabei einfallen könnte? Richtig, du stellst einen großen Touch Queen in den Park und gibst Obdachlosen da irgendwie so Eurojobs von Kehr doch mal hier zusammen mit einem Besen, in dem man einen GPS-Tracker einbaut, damit man auch monitorieren kann, dass die wirklich kehren.
Mit KI.
Mit KI, richtig.
Ist auch eine Blockchain dabei gewesen?
Ich erinnere mich nicht mehr, aber ich würde wetten drauf abschließen.
Ich glaube nicht tatsächlich, aber... Also der Bäcker kann dann praktisch einen Microtask machen. Das Problem ist, dass Leute darauf angewiesen sind, Pfand zu sammeln und so weiter. Stattdessen könnte der Bäcker sagen bei mir vor der Bäckerei, das ist ein Zigarettenstummel und ich mache jetzt einen Microtask. Dann können die Menschen mit dem KI-enabelten Besen kehren und bekommen dann, glaube ich, Trockens. Wenn ich mich nicht ganz zertäusche. Die sind dann auch nur gegen Backwaren eintauschen können. Dieses Projekt wurde von der Vodafone-Stiftung verstetigt.
Was?
Was? Warte mal, lass mich zusammenfassen. Also, wir leben in einer Welt, in der manche Menschen so arm sind, dass sie keine Wohnung haben und Pfannflaschen sammeln müssen, um ihren Lebensunterhalt oder was auch immer sie brauchen, häufig erwerben zu können. Und statt zu versuchen, diese Welt zu verändern, sagen wir, hey, das ist doch mega gut. Wenn die kein Geld haben, können sie sich ja durch ihren Arbeitsethos wieder herausarbeiten. Und wie treiben sie in so eine Art... Ich will jetzt nicht Sklaverei sagen, weil das dann ein überstrapaziertes Bild ist. Aber ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich es sonst nennen soll.
Ähm, das hatte sogar noch einen weiteren Aspekt, fällt mir gerade ein. Sie wollten nämlich nicht nur Geld dafür bezahlen, um Microtasks zu machen, sondern sie wollten dir auch Geld dafür bezahlen, wenn du Verhalten an den Tag klickst, das sie gut finden. Also so was wie, du gehst zu einem Arzt und lässt dich da irgendwie durchchecken. Oder, ich weiß gerade die anderen Beispiele nicht mehr, aber sie hatten ganz viele Beispiele von, wie können wir Leute steuern, damit sie ein gesellschaftlich gewünschtes Verhalten haben.
Aber es war nicht so, dass man einmal pro Tag Blut abgeben musste, um dann den Arzt zu holen. Also, ist das die Quintessenz dieser staatlichen Hackathons? Die sind ja nicht staatlich, sie haben auch Schirmherrschaft. Also ich komm grade nicht so richtig klar. Ich glaub, man könnte das schon auch gut machen. Das ist glaub ich nicht das Problem. Und ich glaub, die Hoffnung war auch bei Weihweißes Virus, dass man da eigentlich in der Civic-Tech-Community auch Gehör verschafft, die seit Jahren sagt, so könnte man's machen, so ginge es besser. Ich glaube, die Beteiligten haben nicht damit gerechnet, dass da Menschen beteiligt sind, die genau in so einer Dimension denken, dass man Dinge durch Autopreneurship lösen sollte, vor allem. Und vor allem durch Privatisierung von Geschichten. Aber ist das nicht sozusagen das Problem, wie immer das Problem? Es gibt ein Projekt oder ein Konzept, das aus so einer, ich verwende das Wort jetzt mal im breitesten Sinne, hippiesken Idee kommt. Also hey, lass mal alle treffen und wochein zusammensetzen, vielleicht kommt da was Geiles raus. Dann wirft man Kapitalismus drauf und dann pervertiert das nicht in die hippie Richtung, sondern eben in die andere. Du hast eben, also ich musste gerade denken, was ich ja am Anfang schon gesagt hatte, da gewinnen halt die Leute mit dem buntesten Pitch Deck und der gewinnbringsten Idee, weil es dann anscheinend letztlich doch nicht darum geht, die Gesellschaft einen besseren Platz zu machen, sondern am meisten Gewinn abzuwerfen.
Ja, Gewinn einerseits oder halt irgendwie Image auf der anderen Seite. Also ich glaube, dass man das auch mit reinnehmen kann, dass es irgendwie gut aussieht.
So, jetzt ist ja das Thema der Sendung eigentlich Hackathon. Kann man also für diesen Anwendungsfall sagen nein? Oder glaubt ihr, es gibt eine Art und Weise, wie man dieses Format auf der Ebene gut einsetzen kann? Oder lasst mich die Frage anders stellen. Ich bin halt jemand, der sozusagen für Digitartechnik empfänglich ist, der klar ist, dass es keine gute Idee ist, Leute zu Microdrops zu verpflichten, die man in Chips einpflanzen. Meine Güte, wir sind ja wirklich fast so weit. Egal. Also ich bin jemand, der sagen, der technische Ahnung oder Verständnis oder Lust darauf hat und der weiß, dass man sozusagen mit Digitalisierung tatsächlich ein bisschen was besser machen kann, nämlich wenn man in diesen Civic-Tech-Bereich geht. Ich möchte also anscheinend nicht an so einem Hackathon teilnehmen. Was mache ich stattdessen? Ja, komm. Wer kann das? Das ist ja wieder die Ausschlussprobe. Ne, tatsächlich, also was man machen könnte, ist im ganz Kleinen, Campaigning. Also gerade dieser Punkt von wegen, es gibt schon ganz viele Beispiele, wo Dinge gezeigt worden sind, wie man das machen kann. Also ganz viel im Civic-Tech-Bereich ist ja auch so, da ist dieses Pattern, ich möchte das gar nicht auf ewig weiter betreiben. Also ich möchte nicht Entrepreneur sein, indem ich halt mal was besser mache, was die öffentliche Hand machen sollte. Und möchte jetzt Funding dafür einwerben. Manche sagen einfach nur, ich hab das gemacht und ich will eigentlich loswerden. Also das sollte die öffentliche Hand selber machen. Kleine Anfragen.de ist so ein Beispiel, wo Bundestagsanfragen erstmals richtig gut durchsuchbar waren und so weiter und so fort. Und das Ziel war da von Anfang an immer von wegen die öffentliche Hand, in dem Fall der Parlamentspiegel, soll das doch selber machen. Der hat das halt sechs Jahre nicht gemacht. Das heißt, hier wäre ein Ansatzpunkt, da muss man nicht programmieren dafür, da muss man nicht coden können. Das Einzige, was man machen muss, wäre da beim jeweiligen Bundestags- oder Landtagsabgeordnetenbüro anzurufen und zu sagen, hey, kennt ihr kleine Anfragen.de zum Beispiel oder vieles andere, was es da gibt? Warum ist das eigentlich immer noch nicht in der öffentlichen Hand und wäre doch Digitalisierung? Da kann man sich doch profilieren mit.
Und wenn ich es jetzt von der anderen Seite sehe, also wenn ich jetzt eine Verwaltung wäre oder höhere Institutionen, dann sind natürlich A, also ich schau einfach mal, was gibt es denn so? Was gibt es denn so für Ideen? Was gibt es denn so für Leute, die sich seit Jahren für ein Thema einsetzen, offensichtlich ohne sich großartig davon was zu versprechen in irgendeiner finanziellen Hinsicht? Also mal gucken, wer ist denn da? Und ich finde es immer so ein bisschen schwierig zu sagen, wir machen noch eine Veranstaltung, weil viele Menschen haben dann halt doch auch eine Familie und ein Privatleben und auch mal Interesse, was anderes zu machen, aber warum nicht einfach Austauschplattformen irgendwie anbieten? Das kann ein Abend sein, das kann ein Barcamp am Wochenende sein, aber einfach wirklich ins Gespräch zu kommen mit den Menschen, die es halt schon sehr lange machen und halt nicht irgendwelche Ideen einfach nur anbieten wollen, sondern sagen, guck mal, das läuft irgendwie schon vier Jahre gut, aber ich bin jetzt fertig mit, weiß ich nicht, meinem Studium und eigentlich schon viel zu lange drüber und ich kann es nicht mehr betreiben. Wie kriegen wir es jetzt hin, dass ihr das macht?
Ich meine, ich bin ja ein Behördenmitarbeiter und mein Job ist, solchen strange Leuten, wie sie hier im Radio gerade sind, zuzuhören und halt ganz intensiv zuzuhören, was die denn machen. Also nicht meine Probleme abzuladen, meine Challenges, sondern mal anzuschauen, was es schon ganz real gibt und dann selber an den Klippen der Verwaltungen zerschellen, damit es die anderen nicht machen müssen. Aber bist du idealisierter Einzelkämpfer oder gibt es sozusagen das, was du machst, schon als regulären Job auch in anderen Verwaltungen? Ich bin da nicht der Einzige, um Gottes Willen. Ich war auch nicht der Erste. Also gerade im Code for Germany Netzwerk beispielsweise, wo ja ganz viele solche Gruppen vernetzt sind, da gibt es viele Menschen, die baden ihre Hände in Stadtverwaltung, in Kommunalverwaltung. Da gibt es auch Überschneidungen mit der Wikipedia-Community und so weiter und so fort. Also da bin ich überhaupt nicht allein. Was aber glaube ich viele von diesen Menschen eint, ist gerade so dieses Hände über den Kopf zusammenschlagen, dass statt der eigentlichen Baustellen jetzt so viel Fokus auf diesen Showveranstaltungen liegt. Ja, Leuchtturmfassaden-Projekte. Das ist so schlimm, wenn man immer wieder an diese Stelle stößt. Also egal, worüber man redet. Ich würde, bevor wir zum Abschluss kommen, Lilith noch mal fragen wollen. Du hast am Anfang erzählt, dass sozusagen dein, nicht Hobby, aber dein Aktivismus sozusagen in die Richtung geht. Es gibt irgendwie ein Gesetz, was e-Digitalisierung vorschreibt und dann machst du irgendwas. Könntest du das noch mal genauer beschreiben? Weil mir scheint es auch in die Richtung zu gehen. Was kann man machen, anstatt auf einen Hackathon zu gehen, auf so einen Hackathon zu gehen?
Genau. Ich hab mich letztes Jahr tatsächlich so halberuflich sehr intensiv angefangen, mit dem Online-Zugangsgesetz zu beschäftigen. Das besagt grundsätzlich, dass bis Ende 2023 alle Verwaltungsleistungen in Deutschland online angeboten werden müssen. Ja, das wird praktisch auch nicht passieren. Dazu hab ich eine ganz große Datenauswertung gemacht, wo ich aufgezeigt habe, dass wir momentan bei einem Umsetzungsstand von 3% liegen. Wenn man sich das komplette Datenframework als Online-Zugangsgesetzes nimmt, fand die Bundesverwaltung zum Teil ziemlich cool, dass ich das gemacht hab, zum Teil nicht. Ich hab mir daraufhin angeschaut, wo liegen denn da ganz konkret die Probleme? Die sind ganz vielschichtig. Wir bräuchten irgendwie einheitliche Formate über Strukturen, wie man sagt, nur sinnvoll gemeinsam, also über mehrere Kommunen und Länder und so weiter hinweg umsetzen kann, technisch, bis hin zu, ja, vielleicht wär's cool, Open-Source-Software zu haben, um viele diese Sachen zu machen. Dann hab ich mich hingesetzt und mal angefangen, als erstes so ein paar der Standards, die tatsächlich die Verwaltung bis heute schon entwickelt hat, rund um das Online-Zugangsgesetz mal in Open-Source-Software umzusetzen. Und hab da außenrum dann als erstes prototypisch mal ein Formularsystem gebaut, das halt für die öffentliche Verwaltung möglichst einfach funktioniert. Und keine Ahnung, ich hab dann über dieses Ding gemerkt, wie unglaublich viele Leute in der Verwaltung es eigentlich schon gibt, die sich mit Open-Source beschäftigen und die sowas richtig cool finden. Die aber halt häufig nicht auf Bundesebene sitzen, sondern die irgendwie auf Landes- und Kommunalebene sitzen. Und da gibt's dann so kleine bayerische Orte wie Treuchtlingen. Die machen seit 20 Jahren Linux auf dem Desktop, haben fast kein Stück Close-Source-Software mehr in ihren Systemen. Und ja, die machen das einfach. Und da laufen viele Sachen richtig gut, aber die brauchen halt irgendwie mehr Unterstützung, die brauchen mehr Infrastruktur und so weiter und so fort. Und mit denen macht es dann richtig Spaß, auch zusammenzuarbeiten. Und das ist dann halt auf einem ganz anderen Ebene, wo man einfach mit der Arbeitsebene, mit der Verwaltung zusammenkommt und nicht im Großen sich hinzusetzen und vor Bundestagsabgeordneten zu pitchen, die von all dem, was die wirklichen Probleme sind, gerade in der Verwaltung, häufig nicht weiter entfernt sein können.
Kann man das irgendwo öffentlich verfolgen, was du machst?
Ja, also Formularium heißt das Ganze. Das kann man auf GitHub sich anschauen. Und ich twittere darüber auch immer wieder. Und ich twittere auch über so Datenauswertungen und alles, was zum OZG halt so mir unter die Finger kommt.
Okay, da schreiben wir auf jeden Fall auch die Show notes. So, nachdem wir jetzt also darüber gesprochen haben, was Hackathons sind und wer sie momentan benutzt, um Aufgaben nicht zu erledigen, die eigentlich erledigt werden sollten. Was macht denn, vielleicht können wir sozusagen auch eine positive Note abschließen, was macht denn für euch einen guten Hackathon aus? Ihr solltet Rücksicht nehmen auf, wer dran teilnehmen kann und wer nicht. Also das fängt damit an, bei so ganz basic Geschichten, von wegen in Zeiten, als wir uns noch in der Hosenwelt alle trafen, hat es ja auch Abhängigkeiten, von wegen, wer kann sich eine Anreise leisten, wer kann sich eine Unterkunft leisten, sonst irgendwie. Das ist zum Beispiel schon mal ein Punkt, wo man über Stipendien auch was machen kann, um auch Leute, die sich sowas nicht leisten können, das zu ermöglichen. Kinderbetreuung ist auch so ein Punkt natürlich, der da eine Rolle spielt. Und selbst dann wird man auch viele, viele, viele Ausschüsse machen. Und was auch immer wieder heißt, dass ganz viele Teile der Gesellschaft nicht abgedeckt sind. Das mitzudenken ist schon mal kein Fehler. Es gibt da einen wunderbaren Vortrag Programming is forgetting, wo Alison Parrish sagt, wir müssen die komplette Hacker-Ethik neu denken und viel breiter aufziehen. Nämlich genau, wen lassen wir eigentlich aus? Das mindestens zu berücksichtigen. Und wenn es dann um die Umsetzung geht, wenn man wirklich sagt, ich möchte jetzt was langfristig weiterverfolgen, wo es nicht nur um meinen Lernspaß geht, es ist die große Aufgabe, erstmal zu schauen, wen gibt es da gerade schon, die sich schon lange mit den Dingen beschäftigen. Und wo ich beitragen kann. Du bist, glaube ich, jetzt bist du aber wieder bei dem, was können wir als Geschäft machen. Ich wollte jetzt wieder zurückgehen zum Hackathon. Zu den Ausrichtern? Genau. Was macht deinen guten Hackathon aus? Also wo wir nicht die Gesellschaft verbessern wollen als Hauptziel, sondern wo wir eine gute Zeit haben können und unser kreatives Hirn anschmeißen. Dann ist die Zielsetzung nur, ich möchte Leute zusammenbringen und vernetzen, oder? Das frag ich dich. Ich bin jetzt jemand, das Format klingt ganz cool. Was wir jetzt gerade gesagt haben, bei Update Deutschland möchte ich wahrscheinlich nicht mitmachen. Aber ich würde es machen, worauf ich achten soll, wenn ich einen Hackathon aussuche, an dem ich teilnehme. Was soll der können? Ach so, wenn du teilnimmst, okay. Da ist wieder die Frage, wenn ich nur laden will, dann ist doch genau der Punkt. Also dann reicht es ja auch schon im Endeffekt zu sagen, das ist ein Thema, dem ich für das ich mich interessiere. Und dann gehe ich rein und dann passt es. Und dann kann ich natürlich auch schauen, da kann ich auch die Veranstaltenden darauf aufmerksam machen, ob sie Leute, ob sie Ausschlüsse provozieren oder ob sie da entsprechend auch auf Zugegängigkeit achten. Das ist schon mal auf jeden Fall ein Vorteil. Aber ich glaube, da ist wieder der große Punkt, dass wir so ein riesiges Feld haben und wir echt dann schauen müssen, was ist eigentlich das Ziel, was ich verfolge. Lass mich die Frage anders stellen. Zu welchem Hackathon gehst du als nächstes und warum? Das wird derjenige Hackathon der Deutschen Bahn sein, der wieder in der Hosenwelt nach der Pandemie stattfindet irgendwann, weil man da schöne, witzige Leute treffen kann und ich Züge mag. Wobei, Bahn klingt auch schon wieder, Aha, Firma, naja gut. Ich glaube, das ist ein wichtiger Punkt an der Stelle, weil das ist einer, wo man sich gegenseitig parasitisch ausnutzt. Das ist nämlich ein ganz spannender Punkt, gerade bei Open Data. Ich meine, die Bahn hat natürlich was davon, wenn sie Leute zu sich ranzieht, und das natürlich auch Employer Branding und so weiter. Aber das ist so eine Geschichte, die kann man halt als Teilnehmende aus der Civic-Tech-Community high checken, weil ich dann auch sagen kann, schau mal hier, ich suche mir Beispiele raus, wo ihr zu wenige offene Daten draus gebt. Dann bohre ich irgendwo vielleicht Schnittstellen an, wo ich an die Daten trotzdem rankomme und sage, schau mal, hat niemandem wehgetan, bitte stell das auch als Open Data bereit. Also da kann man sich schon gegenseitig ein bisschen hochleveln. Das ist nicht die böse Seite. Alles klar. Lilith, wo willst du hin als nächstes? Dein Hackathon? Oder wodurch zeichnet sich ein guter Hackathon für dich aus?
Also ich glaube, dass einfach erst mal transparent sein muss, was das Ziel des Hackathons ist. Und dann sollte das auch noch ein Ziel sein, das nicht ist, wir verändern die Welt, sondern vielleicht wir lernen was zusammen. Das finde ich immer sehr schön. Jetzt ganz konkret durch die Pandemie weiß ich gar nicht, was der nächste Hackathon sein wird, an dem ich mal teilnehmen werde. Ich fände eigentlich Jugendhackt offline irgendwann noch mal ganz cool als Mentorin. Das habe ich vor ein paar Jahren schon mal gemacht und das fand ich sehr schön. Und sonst bin ich mir gar nicht so sicher.
Na okay, aber Jugendhackt kann man ja auch schon mal in der Liste aufnehmen. Julia, ein guter Hackathon ist oder welchen Hackathon möchtest du als nächstes besuchen? Gerne sozusagen nach Rosenwelt Zukunft.
Natürlich auf jeden Fall Jugendhackt. Ich glaube, das ist einfach so mit das beste Konzept, was ich kennengelernt habe und dem ich eigentlich immer eher bestätigt. Sehr gerne würd ich ja auch mal so einen Mentor in den Jugendhackt sehen. Also dass wir dann einfach den ganzen Kram machen können. Und eine Sache, die ich tatsächlich auch sehr gerne mag, weil es dort tatsächlich solche Sachen gibt, wie zum Beispiel ein Stipendium für Leute, die sonst eher nicht auf Hackathons rumlaufen oder wo es auch mal Kaffee und Kuchen gibt und einfach Familien mit Kindern und allen Möglichen aus der Stadt gerade vorbeikommen können, ist der Hackday in Mörs. Zumindest hab ich den immer als sehr offen erlebt und dort auch so die ersten Workshops mitnehmen dürfen, wo dann irgendwie ein Thomas Tursich erzählt, was ist denn das eigentlich mit den offenen Daten und so die ersten Schritte kann man da, finde ich, sehr gut machen. Und da kann man auch sehr gut die nächsten Schritte gehen. Deswegen, wahrscheinlich Hackday in Mörs, so abgesehen von Jugendhack, was wahrscheinlich eh in meinem Herzen einfach drin ist.
Alles klar, also verschiedene Sachen heute gelernt. Was ein Hackathon ist, dass Jugendhack anscheinend der beste Hackathon der Welt ist und wofür man ihn nicht verwenden kann und worauf man sozusagen achten sollte. Vielen lieben Dank euch, dass ihr heute hier wart und mir so ausführliche Rede und Antwort und meine ganzen Fragenertragen habt gestanden habt. Vielen Dank Stefan, Julia und Lilith. Und mir bleibt zum Abschluss der Sendung nur noch eine ganz wichtige Sache zu sagen, die natürlich auch vor oder für Hackathons gelten. Lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschüttelt immer schön eure Backups.